the breaking news that uh we can bring
you is that sanju javid
has been confirmed as the new health
secretary
our political correspondent is at
standing by in westminster
forest rob yes in many ways um i think
julian sajid javid was something of a
ready-made senior cabinet minister for
boris johnson
to pick and put into the health brief
without the need for any type of wider
reshuffle of course his last position in
the cabinet was that he took
on the role um as chancellor uh when
boris johnson moved into number 10 he
went into number 11.
he of course left that position over an
argument
about whether he should share his
advisory team with number 10 there'd
been a desire
for a shared team to work between number
10 and number 11.
that was received by sajid javid um at
the time
um as a sort of land grab by downing
street taking away
some of the independence and the power
that he would have
which is why he decided to resign and
rishi sunak
came in uh anyway that was 13th of
february
he resigned of course in the coming
weeks really
the world changed in terms of covid
rolling in and the role of the
chancellor
was morphed from what it had been before
as well before that he has a lot of
experience
in cabinet as well he was the business
secretary the culture secretary the
community secretary the home secretary
as well so someone with a lot of top
level
cabinet experience and he will need
every inch of it i think
if um he is going to uh succeed in this
very very
challenging brief because of course it's
not just the fallout
from covid and the pandemic that he will
have to deal with we're not
fully out of it yet but that we are also
going through the nhs is going through
a real pinch point and pressure point in
terms of catching up
with missed operations and missed
treatments then there is an extensive
program of reform that matt hancock
had set in motion in the past few months
to really reorganize
how the nhs runs and reverse many of the
reforms the lansley reforms pushed
through during the coalition years
under david cameron and then on top of
that remember the full title is not just
health secretary it's health
and social care secretary there is a
promised reform
and plan to social care that has been
long promised by many prime ministers
including boris johnson and never
delivered on
that is something that is getting
increased political heat in the recent
weeks
and that is something that will be right
at the top of sagitt javid's
in tray add into that the chief
executive of the nhs
simon stevens is also due to leave his
post
this summer that was something that was
far more long planned and not spurred on
by
any of uh similar reasons to the context
in which matt hancock left
so sadget javid will be coming in and
working with
a new chief executive of the nhs
at a point where the nhs has just gone
through the biggest challenge
it has potentially ever faced at a point
where they are standing
on the edge of a huge swathe of reforms
so this is potentially one of the most
uh daunting briefs in government at the
moment
and potentially one of the most daunting
appointments but he is someone with a
lot of experience he is someone that
when he left
government even though it was on the
back of
an argument around um with boris johnson
and downing street
about the makeup of his team and his
advisory team he made it very clear
at the time that he would be happy to
come back um
into government and that is what we are
seeing now putting put back in
one of the most prominent cabinet
positions
um at the moment and i think it will be
interesting to see whether he carries on
with uh those reforms that matt hancock
had started or whether he tries to go
um in a different direction but
i think any time cabinet positions open
up or there is rumors of a reshuffle
rumors
of sajid javid's return to office
circulate today was no different but
this time
they have proved to be true uh and he is
being brought
back into cabinet i imagine this does
suggest
that there won't be a wider reshuffle
that this will just be
um a single swap out and swap in uh
rather than anything more substantial
and uh rob in terms of um sajid javi
being a safe
pair of hands he has been out of cabinet
for
some time but is that generally how he's
regarded i think he is regarded um
in the current circumstances as probably
one of the safer pair of hands you could
put in
uh if you look at some of the other
names that have been floating around
there had been rumors about nadeem
zahawi the current vaccines minister
stepping up but that
nadim tahawi is someone that although uh
being involved in the very successful
vaccine program is someone with
uh no cabinet experience i believe and
only a few years of ministerial
experience so that would have been
a very big step up um for him
other names linked to it include michael
gove someone that when he has gone into
other departments including the
department for education
um has been proved to be someone that
although controversial in many ways
can actually get things done can
actually force through agendas
and i think that reputation for michael
gove is the reason why many people
linked him with health
somewhere where you are dealing with
huge huge institutions
and bags and bags of bags of red tape so
you really need
to be something of a political force in
order to bend all of that
to your will and try to push through
change that you want to see
ultimately though michael gove is in
another position with bigger challenges
on his plate
as well and maybe the calculation was in
number 10 that actually it was a lot
easier to put sachit javid in
i think on the whole as well it's not
necessarily a politically controversial
appointment you won't find i think too
many people um
feeling that their noses have been put
out of joint by this because he is
someone that has got so much cabinet
experience
and he is someone that is coming from
the outside um and back in so
uh yes i think in a way it seemed uh
like
the obvious choice both in the
circumstances and looking at sajid
javid's
cv but that's not to say this is going
to be
an easy job for him also he is someone
that doesn't
really come with too much baggage and i
think
that was important to put someone in in
that position
where there is no potential chance
of anything going wrong in the same vein
that it has gone wrong
with matt hancock so i think an
indication that they wanted
they didn't want this to be long and
drawn out they didn't want this to be a
long
reshuffle in downing street they wanted
this to be a quick changeover
and i expect the messaging that will be
put out by
the government um this evening and in
the coming days will be this is all
about
uh a sort of seamless transition this is
all about continuing
with the vaccine program this is all
about reopening uh
next month july the 19th that final
terminus date as it has been known
and this is not about wider
reorganization this is about putting
someone in
who has cabinet experience that is seen
as a safe pair of hands
to carry on where matt hancock has
left off
okay rob um just in terms of the the
reshuffle that had been muted that it
was something that boris johnson
was thinking of but this obviously
circumvents that and there's no need
it's a
one bringing in a minister who hasn't
been in cabinet
and therefore there isn't the need to
reshuffle everybody else so it is a
a very simple one move yeah i think
reshuffles have been doing the rounds in
the westminster rumor mill
for weeks if not months now but this
does make it a lot more straightforward
i think the other thing that boris
johnson may have done
is move someone else like oliver dowd in
his culture secretary into health and
then backfill him with sajid javid in
the end he clearly felt
the cleanest and the easiest thing to do
was to bring someone in
who could just fill that vacancy without
the need
for any of the other reorganizations and
the headaches that can come
with that and in sagittar javid he has
someone
that has the cv to do that and someone
that i think
the party will probably receive on the
whole
fairly warmly